IDO there's so much serendipity in the
fact that this even got made how did you
find this as it's just as astonishing I
think it's the way kudamon found
Samantha it's actually I know kutiman
for many years and very for many years I
all I always want to do something
inspired by his work and when he showed
me the project that included the songs
of Samantha was like starting to play
with the idea of making film and I was
sure that I want to do this film in the
beginning of several musicians in there
in different places around the world all
of them appear in Kuta man's work to
document their life of course the moment
of revealing but when he showed me
Samantha something really I fell in love
with their songs with their honesty with
directness and I really wanted to to
know her to meet her and then I went to
us and we got in touch with Samantha and
very fast with felt very comfortable
with each other and felt that you know
and the same evening we met we went to
this open mic evening something like you
saw in the film in New Orleans and I
totally fell in love with New Orleans
and this music music scene and with
Samantha and and I had a strong feeling
that this is what I want to do but at
that point Samantha didn't know that
kutiman was working no I I was I told
her that I wanted to do a film about you
to youtubers in different places around
the world a musician that upload the
music and hope that people will see and
maybe something will come out for me and
so kudamon you've been doing these
mashups for a while your work was at the
Guggenheim and then all of a sudden you
run across this remarkable voice this
this very frank and honest face
storytelling on YouTube yes and did she
at that point you said I have to do
something with her or was she just one
of many people that you were looking at
and considering for your next piece
actually with with her song I started
first with the music I just I did a big
change in my life and I started this
project working on this project and well
I started with the music so I had the
track ready and I was searching for a
vocalist for it and the track has a
certain BPM and a certain scale so it
couldn't be any any vocalist and then my
search for a few days and then I found
her and I was really amazed and he
actually made me wanna start wanna do
the whole album and and Samantha for you
you had been putting these videos on
YouTube and finally you saw that people
were listening in a big way
oh yeah and what does that feel like it
was I was at a point in my life where I
was like down and just out of it going
running on autopilot so for that to
happen at that moment it was great it
was beautiful it was like I kept getting
all these wonderful comments and for
people to hear my voice this song and I
have for so long up there it was amazing
I just felt like a surreal moment but
like I said I didn't think beyond it I
just was like this is dope fresh sauce
and then after that it was like okay so
I didn't think like what next I just was
like this is always thing like there's a
beginning and it's like okay the song
was out it did good okay they hear my
voice and it's over anything beyond it
and could him on you were looking for a
voice but you found a whole person out
there so how did you feel about that did
you feel I'm watching something really
intimate and should I be hearing this
about this person when I'm looking for
her voice but seeing so much more of her
I don't know I just I just kind of
virtually fell in love with her you know
you know oh yeah there was something I
don't know there was something so real
and honest about her and I watched so
many you know I spent so much time
watching a lot of people singing in a
lot of them a lot of the times or trying
you know hi I'm
this and that and I'm trying to look
cool imitating other people yeah and
trying you know trying to be someone
someone else and something about her
honesty really caught me and I really
fell in love with that and you know how
hard was this just mechanically and from
an editing point of view from the first
it was very hard distance you know is
Israel New Orleans it's like I found
myself most of the time and you know I
really wanted to be there more so I was
like every morning I remember I was
waking up and watching your Instagram
channel to see what's going on and then
when she didn't know you had somebody
who was watching you know but afterward
after we started the filming you know I
I beg to went back to Israel and then I
checked their Instagram and she you
talked about going to d'void to audition
for them all said okay it's time to go
to New Orleans it was like a year of
going back back and forth and it was a
real channel challenge but in terms of
editing I must say that this in felt in
this film it's really was totally
different experience from other things
that I did I felt that their karma were
went to this film and I was like going
to New Orleans put you know the material
on the timeline just need to clean it up
a little and the scenes were there and
slowly slowly it's become a film
Samantha what did he tell you why he was
showing up and why he wanted to film you
well his wife
hit me on hit me oh yeah know what I
mean you know what that means right hit
me on Facebook huh okay it hit me on
Facebook and said um he wanted a
documentary about youtubers and I was
like okay why not you'd only get one
chance in life why not try this I never
tried it before and so he came down like
he said I met him in his hotel lobby
rest in peace to Prince that's a song is
you know that song okay Nikki but anyway
so I read even this hotel every we we we
talked I felt it's like like calm with
him like I can be at that moment I feel
like it was time to tell my story like
at that moment with him he was the one
so we went to open mic night and from
there he just kept coming back but in
his initial visit
his mission was a documentary about
youtubers but it just slowly narrowed
down to me and Cody did after a while
did you forget the camera was there yeah
cuz it was just one camera and one guy
and he wasn't like whoa he did close-ups
he was very close but when he did like
this regular film and he was like way
like a fly on a wall he just wanted to
keep out of my space and he did and so
after a while I become I forgot he was
there like I just look around my normal
day and didn't notice him until like he
scared me when I look over he's still
there so yeah and you know to get
backing and financing and distribution
for this how hard was this was it
something that you said I can't describe
it to you I have to show you it's
something first the fact that I found by
myself and editing it gave me a lot of
you know I should say freedom in the
list in the beginning to check and try
things and and that's what I did and
after the first visit in New Orleans
that I came back with such a strong
feeling and I edited something and then
I came with the my enthusiasm to like
the Israeli tel aviv channel and the
foundation and they really when to go
wanted to go with me with on this
journey and it started to it was easier
than other projects i think they also
fell in love with them and how different
is this from other work that you have
done i so used to suffer when i do films
you know in my documentaries and most of
them i'm very depressing and like you
know about israel one of them was very
political and it was in this this was
totally different experience there was
something so you know i really enjoyed
you know also the visits and also the
editing i was editing and song started i
knew that i need to do a cut but i
couldn't you know till the end this song
is ending i was just listening it was
really something that usually when film
is finished it's kind of relief and like
people i I and people are very happy I'm
kind a little said it is and this
this journey of this filmmaking because
I really I really loved it that's a very
rare compliment but it's not in English
till you know and I can also say that
something that I really felt in this
film and I believe you know that music
and creating there is power of healing
and and it's for me and came in time in
my life that it's really I should I say
it's it was big thing for me well
Samantha in your YouTube videos you were
so honest about everything including
being molested as a child because you
weren't thinking this was going to go
viral to use the word that millions of
people would not only hear your voice
but see these stories did that make you
feel differently about doing the videos
after the fact
no like I you know when I when I it's
just me at that moment moment it's just
me and my phone you don't think beyond
the phone you just think this is going
here you push publish and I left it
alone but after like a little bit after
when a documentary was like I'm like
this oh God then I just like oh well it
is what it is I got you know it was like
a moment of oh my god like I like set up
in bed and was like oh my god but after
that it was like hey this is life and
people go through this every day it's
not just me so I want people to know
that it's reality and everybody's not
like a millionaire and people suffering
people struggling people right now
there's somebody being abused right now
so like there is abuse and I want people
to realize that and what did you think
when you saw his footage of her
listening to your mashup that was that
was really amazing and touching for me
now you know now when I watch the fear
my just kind of don't feel anything
anymore because I watched it so many
times but for me the reveal the real
moments were when he came back and
showed me the you know the scenes where
she discovered and all all the powerful
scenes in the film it was really
touching for me and you said you didn't
really want to let the film go but were
there surprises did the film take you
places that you hadn't expected it to
take you
I think this rises
it's it's the reactions of the audience
it's something that we were traveling
for European here and the reaction was
really very emotional it's I'm very
excited about it
and people may respond to your personal
story as much as they do to your music
you know a lot of people approached me a
lot of people that are like they're in
their net wounded state that I was in
and I know where they are and so I don't
like sometimes you feel I feel like my
hands are bound because it's the process
they have to go through by their self
like I can talk to you all day and night
about my strolling what I went through
but you have your own trauma but it's
beautiful that I'm able to talk to
people I talked it's like hours I sit
and talk to them and they're emotional I
want to help them and bring them out of
it so it's a beautiful thing when people
embrace you and tell you I'm a survivor
to let you know okay it's okay we're not
victims we're survivors
before we let you go can you sing for us
sitting on the window seat staring at
the rain outside asking you why you
don't love me at all babe I'm stuck in
same place million miles away from the
truth but it's in funny of face and
please thank the panel rocks off